why is it that Ramadan specifically is
put on its own in terms of uh it being
welcomed what about other months like
Hajj the month of Hajj Etc the reason we
Muslims welcome the month of Ramadan all
the months in the year are good
alhamdulillah but the reason we
specifically welcome the month of
Ramadan because Ramadan is a month of
forgiveness it is a month where I
mentioned earlier our beloved Prophet M
wasallam said that the doors of heaven
will be
opened the Gates of Hell will be closed
and the Devils will be chained so
because of this
reason this month is welcom and whatever
deed we do it will be multiplied 10
times the reward that we get for every
deed in this month is 10 times more
because of this and whatever we ask for
forgiveness as our beloved Prophet said
that if we fast for the full month of
Ramadan which with the true intention
and with proper Faith asking reward from
Allah subhana wa taala all our passing
will be forgiven mentioned sari Vol
number three book of fasting Hadith
number 1901 so because of this
purpose this month is welcomed so that
we look forward for our sins to be
forgiven and for our Deeds to be
multiplied our Good Deeds to be
multiplied that is the reason
specifically we Muslims we welcome this
month of r